first came networks then mobile video
cloud social analytics
internet-of-things cognitive each new
innovation creates tremendous
opportunity but also generates more and
more data data that is multiplied
exponentially as its created shared
copied stored and shared again as
unstructured data grows exponentially it
creates a challenge how to store and
manage all this data so that your
company can access and take advantage of
it for your business traditional
on-premise storage was never designed to
handle data at this scale it offers
control but at scale traditional storage
is far too complex and costly today you
need a new approach that helps manage
data growth and unpredictability that
can balance storage costs location
performance and compliance needs across
data sets and essential applications you
need a solution that's flexible scalable
and simple
that's IBM Cloud object storage a new
approach to storage that's flexible
scalable and simple to manage it's the
only storage flexible enough for today's
changing needs flexible to buy ready to
work with today's data intensive apps
choose IBM Cloud object storage standard
for your high-performance applications
and workloads that need to be accessed
frequently we support for s3 api's IBM
cloud object storage vault service is
ideal for archive backup and other less
frequently accessed workloads delivered
across the IBM cloud both standard and
vault cloud services can be deployed in
regional or cross regional models to
give you durability security and
availability you cux tracked more
business value from your data than ever
so you can enable compelling customer
experiences new innovative business
models and faster flexible operations
all leveraging your data and the IBM
cloud unmatched flexibility
massive scalability powerful simplicity
IBM Cloud object storage flexible
storage built for rapid change
[Music]
you